There’s a lot of people out there claiming
to know the best diet, based on what our ancestors
ate.
But how do we separate the hogwash from the
history?
Hey guys, Julia here for DNews.
There are some people who like to make inferences
on how we should live based on some “ideal”
past.
Take a recent trendy diet.
The basic tenets of the paleo diet come from
a few current hunter-gather societies, suggesting
we should eat more like we did before the
invention of agriculture.
We want an easy answer for how we should live,
or more specifically eat, but the real story
is so much more complex.
So what does evidence say ancient humans ate?
From looking at teeth, skull fragments, environmental
conditions, and even computer models, our
ancestors lived in a wide range of habitats,
leading to a variety in diets.
Optimal Foraging theory suggests that diet
is influenced by a food’s value and distribution
within the habitat.
For most of human-ish history we were hunter
gatherers.
Well, mostly gatherers.
Before 4 million years ago, our ancestors
ate a surprising amount of fruits and leaves,
similar to how chimps eat now.
Researchers found isotopic evidence in teeth
enamel of a transition around 3.5 million
years ago, early hominid species starting
expanding their diets.
They added other plants, like tubers, roots,
and succulents.
The researchers had to add that perhaps these
isotopes are from animals they ate, that ate
the plants.
Speaking of meat, it’s not certain when
meat entered early human’s diet.
Whether hunted or scavenged, researchers find
evidence of marks on animal bones dating back
2.6 million years.
A skull found in Tanzania dating back 1.5
million years ago showed that meat had become
crucial for brain development in early humans.
It’s thought that eating meat regularly
triggered changes in our brains, making us
the kind of smart apes we are today.
Then there’s teeth.
You can tell a lot by the teeth.
Teeth size and shape and even how our jaws
fit together tell a story.
We have bunodont - back teeth that are low
with rounded cusps that lend themselves well
to eating below ground food, roots, tubers,
the like.
Our crooked teeth are probably the result
of cooking food.
Cooking opened up a new way of getting nutrients.
But our teeth changed with the invention of
fire.
As we started softening our food by cooking,
our jaws got smaller, but our teeth haven’t
caught up yet.
hence all the crowding and crooked teeth.
Then about 12,000 years ago we settled down
in communities and started growing our own
food rather than foraging for it.
This is commonly called the Neolithic Revolution
or Neolithic Demographic Transition.
During this time, humans introduced cereals
into their diet - the Neolithic Founder Crops,
including, wheat, barley, lentils and peas.
Although, there’s evidence that of charred
barley and wheat from Israel dating to about
23,000 years ago.
There also some evidence that might move back
the introduction of grain into the human diet
to about 100,000 years ago.
Researchers from the University of Calgary
found starch granules on stone tools.
Evidence found in pottery shards suggest that
humans also added dairy products to their
diets, around 7,000 years ago.
While these advances are more recent, our
guts evolved to keep up.
A genetic mutation in central Europe just
over 7 thousand years ago for humans to make
drinking milk a thing.